في هذه الاثناء سفيان وكما نرى عبر الشاشه
اهالي طولكرم
يسيرون في جنازه
ويحملون نعشى الشهيدين سامر الشافعي وحمزه
خريوش والذين يبلغان من العمر اثنين
وعشرين عاما ونرى ايضا والده احد الشهيدين
تحمل نعش ابنها وتردد بان على الجميع
الوحده
والانتقام بالطبع حاله من الغضب الشديد لا
تسود فقط طولكرم بل تسود كل انحاء الضفه
الغربيه بالطبع الجنازه ستكون بشكل رسمي
بعد صلاه ظهر هذا اليوم فقط لنعيد
والتفكير سفيان بما حدث قوات خاصه تسللت
بذي مدني فلسطيني دخلت الى مخيم نور شمس
في طولكرم حاصرت احد المنازل اشتبكت مع
على الاقل المقاومين الشهيدين سامر وحمزه
رفضه تسليم نفسيهما ويظل الاشتباك متواصل
حتى قامت قوات الاحتلال باغتيالهما هناك
اصابه ثالثه ايضا في الاطراف وصلت الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت بطبع بعد دخول القوات
الخاصه وكما كنا قد راينا في المرات
الماضيه خلال المجازر التي ارتكبتها قوات
الاحتلال فور دخول القوات الخاصه تدخل
اليات عسكريه
للمسانده وكنا قد راينا ايضا يوم الخميس
الماضي قبل يومين كيف اغتالت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثلاثه شهداء
فلسطينيين وراينا كيف تم نشر صور القوات
الخاصه بانها كانت ترده ترتدي ازياء
النساء وايضا عمال النظافه
بارتقاء الشهيدين اليوم يرتفع عدد الشهداء
حتى هذه اللحظه الى 112 شهيدا نقول حتى
هذه اللحظه لان الفلسطينيين لم يعودوا
يعرفون ماذا سيحدث في الساعه القادمه